Why do green chemistry, why
do green chemistry? You know,
it's not my job. You know, I like to
talk about the chef. This is the meals.
I make a delicious,
sure they are poisonous,
but there are other shuts
working on nonlethal
cook,
the architect that says the homes I
build on luxurious and beautiful. Yes,
they collapse and kill
people on a regular basis.
But there are other people working
on safe house. The car designer,
it says, I build cars that are
fast, powerful, beautiful. Yes,
they fall apart unexpectedly
when people die.
But there are other designers
working on sustainable cars.
Okay.
And then the chemist.
I've developed some of
the best methodologies and
processes from making hundreds
of target molecules, target molecules
that are improving the world.
Sure they harm humans and the environment.
But there are other chemists
working on green chemistry
for the same reason that the
first three examples were absurd.
This is absurd.
And yet throughout the
history of chemistry,
and sadly even in large swaths today,
this is not considered absurd.
This is considered the orthodoxy
that green chemistry is not my job.
It's somebody else's job.
Somebody else has to worry about it.
I'm just doing research.
I'm just making this widget.
I'm just making this shampoo. I'm
somebody else. The engineer's,
we'll clean up the, uh, uh, the
waste, et Cetera, et cetera.
And what we understand now is that we
can have the building blocks of chemistry
of the economy that doesn't have to
have these unintended consequences.